today you can get millions of views on
your brand or business completely for
free and basically nobody's utilizing it
over the last couple years learning this
cheat code has been my biggest Focus so
now here I am to teach you everything
prior to this whole content Journey
which is why you've seen my face popping
up so much more lately I had my full
focuses on my businesses each with their
core fundamentals based around this
cheat code Tick Tock marketing I did
work in the crypto space
brand other people's tick tocks sold out
shows for stand-up comedians ran
promotional accounts flipped accounts
all generating me over 5 million dollars
over the past two years so here are the
top 7 tech talk tips allowing me to do
so one when you make your account you
need tick tock to see you as a Creator
rather than a bot or a consumer account
so what are some of these companies
biggest problems that they face bot
accounts so you need a proof to tick
tock you're a real person specifically a
Creator rather than a bot fake account
so to do this there's a few steps you
want to do you want to connect your
email to your Tick Tock account you want
a professional looking profile picture
and bio before ever posting on this
account you want at least 10 drafts
saved in your account and you want to
scroll on the for you page for at least
one to two days before ever posting
specifically in the niche you're going
to post in so if you're going into the
crypto Niche you want to be scrolling on
crypto videos before ever posting I
don't need to go too deep into this now
I have a more in-depth tutorial in my
Discord server I'll leave the link in
the description so you can check it out
after this video two look at what the
top people in your Niche do and copy it
in your own way this is basically as
simple as it sounds when starting my
YouTube account I analyzed who did the
best mom reacts before me cuff boys so I
copied his most viral titles because I
know that works who was popping off when
I started posting sneako so I copied his
exact thumbnail style who was the best
with video descriptions and targeting
the Right audience fit IQ so I copied
his description format exactly and
implemented it in my own way with my own
keywords even in the nft space when I
started the holy nft account the third
video on this brand new account got over
7 million views how do we do it we
copied somebody else's video we saw that
did well and we did it better this was
the third most viral video on our whole
account basically completely ripped off
from somebody else who was at the top of
the nft niche at the time cheating look
at any of your top influencers they all
do the same thing you just don't notice
it now that I mention this look at all
the top correlations that they have
between their viral posts crazy number
three you want to find creative way ways
to drive people to your Lincoln bio so
as we all know all these social media
companies have one major goal in mind to
keep us on their platforms for as long
as possible so if you make it obvious
that you're trying to drive people to
your link by putting link and bio
directly in the description Tick Tock
won't push your video as far because
they know you're trying to drive people
off of their platforms you want to be
creative you want to think of different
ways to direct people to your Lincoln
bio without directly alerting the social
media companies that that's your goal
there's tons of different ways to do
this I have a whole channel in my
Discord exclusively for how to drive
people to your Lincoln bio properly
because it's just that important four
always use hashtags directly related to
your video don't use [ __ ] like hashtag
fyp and hashtag viral because that
doesn't help Tick Tock know what
audience to push our videos to basically
what we're doing on Tick Tock is giving
them the tools they need to push our
videos to the Right audience so if
you're making cooking videos or you run
a restaurant use hashtag Cooking
restaurant hashtag home meals stuff like
that so that Tick Tock will push it to
that specific audience rather than if
you used hashtag fyp and then they would
just be pushing it to a broader group of
people and your video wouldn't be
getting as good of metrics which is what
we're going for if I was posting my
videos on Tick Tock I'd use hashtag
Sunny fast hashtag entrepreneur hashtag
teen hashtag business hashtag momreacts
stuff like that number five you always
want to use an audio in your videos
there's multiple benefits to doing this
Tick Tock pushes your video out more
when you use an audio on it and it makes
the risk of your audio getting taken
down off of tick tock to zero if you
don't use an audio on your video and you
just post it normally Tick Tock can rip
that audio off for no reason it's very
easy to find what audios you should use
so for example if you're in the red pill
Niche I would go to the top of hashtag
Tate and just scroll down from the top
and just save all the videos that they
use
this is the same with whatever Niche
you're posting in and it goes back to
what I was talking about earlier with
copying what you see does well you're
going to the top of whatever hashtag of
the niche you're in and just seeing what
those top accounts are using for audios
and then you're using those in your own
videos we're looking at what works and
we're copying it that's what we're doing
number six make sure your hook is very
engaging the most important metric Tick
Tock uses is making sure that you have
75 percent of people still watching your
video three seconds in watch your video
from an unbiased point of view think if
I had a goldfish attention span would I
keep watching this video or when I
scroll right away you need to grab the
viewer right away say something
controversial make sure your video is
very easy to follow along aesthetically
pleasing zero room for confusion because
at the end of the day if a viewer is
confused they're gonna scroll nobody's
sitting there to try and figure out
what's going on in this Tick Tock people
have zero attention spans number seven
post every video you make on reels and
shorts too this is by far the biggest
mistake people make I've had videos get
8K used on Tick Tock and then go to get
over a million views on shorts you're
already making the video which is the
hard part so you might as well take the
extra two minutes to go post it on reels
and shorts too which both have just as
good of a chance as going viral as Tick
Tock especially since YouTube shorts has
a revenue split coming with creators in
a few months so you getting ahead now
will allow you to start making bank by
the time that system rolls out trust me
when I say these Tick Tock tips are not
something you'd want to ignore the first
thing that I think of whenever I start a
new business is how can I Market it on
Tick Tock because it's free views if
you're looking to test your skills be
able to make some money right away and
learn from me about how to do these
tricks then you can join my Discord
server I'll leave the link in the
description I have an affiliate program
free to anyone so you can start making
money right away I have in-depth guides
going into all these topics that I
talked about inside of this video and
I'm hiring top Affiliates to come work
for me with me at my agency so you'll be
provided with work online alright guys
see you inside peace
[Music]